greetings dudes I'm Walter Binet dziak
and this is top five with his new movie
Siberia coming out later this week now
is a great time to finally talk about
one of my favorite actors who could that
be you ask close enough it's canneries
in his 30 plus year career Keanu Reeves
has had true staying power in addition
to seemingly not aging Cannell has been
a part of some very high grossing and
memorable franchises across his time on
the big screen with hits like Point
Break and speed establishing him as an
action star Kiana's versatility is
without a doubt something special at 53
years old he's still leading big
franchises with the John wick series
which will have its third film released
next year but what are the best roles
this Hollywood icon is inhabited over
his long period on top these are the top
5 best Keanu Reeves performances number
5 Harry in the last time I committed
suicide this is not a well known movie
and overall it's not really that great
but Keanu is amazing in it I've never
seen him in a role like this one this
film centers around Neal Cassady the
1960s counterculture icon and is based
off his work the John Anderson letter
the story is nonlinear and follows
Cassidy as he describes his experiences
before and after his longtime girlfriend
attempts to commit suicide along the way
we meet his friends who all have
problems of their own
Keanu is pathetic in this and I mean
that in the best way his character is a
depressed drunk who's sort of temps
nailed to give in to his darker and more
wild impulses Senor eyes brother it's in
your soul you are meant to roam the
plains live off the fat of the land or
the land while that scene may be the
height of his performance he spends a
lot of his screen time either begging
Neal to hang out with him or help him
get a girl to keep him company is she
coming down or what
he's telling you news this up Neil
I need this I wish this movie was just
centered on him or expand his character
so we could see more of his performance
it's sad its raw and it's something you
should go out of your way to see even if
the movie surrounding this character
isn't very good I am a creep
hell you know that I know that it's good
that she knows that get things out in
the open
start with honesty that's what my old
man said before he took off and I might
add that creepiness just so happens to
be one of my most power to the trace
maybe we could just have less of Adrien
Brody in it
number four Ted Theodore Logan the third
in Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure and
bogus journey in excellent adventure
bill and Ted are highschool friends who
are trying to start a band the problem
is they can't play any instruments after
they find out they'll fail history if
they don't do well on their final
assignment Ted's father threatens to
send him to military school soon after a
phone booth appears containing Rufus a
time traveler who tells the duo they
eventually bring about world peace with
their music he gives them the phone
booth so they can travel to different
periods in history and help them pass
their assignment in bogus journey bill
and Ted are killed by robots of
themselves from the future in order to
find a way back they wander the
afterlife and eventually challenge the
Grim Reaper to a game to win back their
lives and stop the evil robotic versions
of themselves
first off excellent adventure is great
and all but I never hear anybody talk
about how much better bogus journey is I
mean it's not even close
bogus journey is like that weird sequel
to a popular movie that never got made
and we've only been able to see concept
art of except they actually made it how
do you up the game from history class
time travel to Kill Bill and Ted with
future robotic versions of themselves
send them to hell play games against the
Grim Reaper send them to heaven had them
recruit an alien scientist that builds
good robot versions of them all while
making the characters even more likeable
than in the first movie this is the best
sequel of all time
take a hike Godfather - screw off Dark
Knight Bill & Ted's bogus journey wins
- later God whether you think they're
supremely entertaining or just
dumb Keanu and Alex winter created
iconic long-lasting characters and Ted
is hilarious put them in the army-navy
excellent well they're from medieval
England
medieval England Iowa dog Patra nice me
well whatever do you got a lot to learn
about sportsmanship well I don't know
where they're gonna go after the ending
of bogus journey I'm looking forward to
billing Ted three I'm just hoping it can
be as wacky and off-the-wall nuts as the
other films you'll see be excellent to
each other
number three FBI agent Johnny Utah in
Point Break this was the movie that
changed the trajectory of Kiana's career
Johnny Utah is a rookie cop in the FBI
who has given an undercover assignment
to infiltrate a gang of robbers called
the dead presidents these thieves are
actually free-spirited surfers who are
addicted to dangerous thrills as Utah
gets closer to busting them he starts to
fall for a female surfer which
complicates this situation Keanu Reeves
as a surfer wasn't really that for a
fetch at the time but he was also an FBI
agent Point Break is a lot of fun with
cheesy early 90s aspects to it and
really well done action sequences
it proved Keanu could do more than just
play a high schooler and after this his
career as an action star was in full
swing he met
yeah Gary Busey also plays Gary Busey in
this I'm so hungry I could eat a sin out
of a dead wino Anthony Kiedis is there
as well but he just can't top flee as
needles in Back to the Future 2 & 3
thanks bird fly in all seriousness Keanu
got to show off his range in this film
and he had someone great to bounce off
of and Patrick Swayze
[Music]
con Dios number two John wick in John
wick in older Keanu Reeves as a retired
hitman hell-bent on getting revenge on a
gang of bad guys I was in from the
premise alone after his wife quickly
passes away from an illness she leaves
John wick a puppy as a final gift soon
wick is drawn out of retirement as a
legendary assassin when a gang of thugs
steal his car and kill his dog hunting
them down won't be easy as their leader
is the son of a local crime boss with
past ties to wit this was the right role
at the right time for kin he had just
hit 50 years old but still had all the
looks and athleticism to be an action
star this may have been the role kyani
was born to play
he just had to age into it John wick is
ruthless aggressive filled with anger
and rage but we feel an immense amount
of sympathy for he's been through so
much and just wants to be left alone but
this classic premise pulls him out of
his self-imposed exile to the fullest
effect possible in a lot of scenes
Reeves doesn't even have to speak we
know what he's thinking just by seeing
his eyes when the Beast does come out
though it's believable it's scary and
it's some of the best work of his whole
career I'm taking on back so you can
either hand
it's clear that this character connected
with a lot of people and only Keanu
Reeves could have pulled off John wick
this definitively Keanu's career has
been a most excellent adventure so
before we get to number one I want to
give you a few honorable mentions make
sure you watch the first one here it's
an incredible and strange hidden gem
[Music]
and the number one best Keanu Reaves
performance is Chris Townsend in
permanent record chances are you've
never heard of this movie because I sure
as hell never did but in my mind it
without a doubt features kion whose best
performance David is the guy in high
school that everybody likes he's smart
funny and is always busy doing something
he seems perfectly happy which is why
it's such a shock to his friends and
family when he commits suicide David's
best friend Chris has been hit very hard
by his friends passing in grieves any
different way than the rest of the
school eventually he decides to start
carrying on David's legacy and takes on
projects he was working on before he
died that pressure combined with some
self-destructive behavior over David's
death leads Chris down a dark road in
the shadow of this tragedy just as Keanu
aged into John wick he was always great
at playing younger characters too
specifically here chris is a conflicted
young man at a crossroads in his life he
was the one who saw his best friend
commit suicide right in front of them
and it is a brilliantly shot scene to
convey the confusion and despair that
followed after this Chris goes from an
easygoing kid not quite fulfilling his
potential to a very angry person lashing
out at friends and family while asking
himself if he could have done anything
to save his friend on top of his
feelings people are looking to him for
comfort which does not go well he starts
realistically spiraling downwards and
feels like an authentic person this is
one of the most well done high school
character performances I've ever seen
all the reactions to David's death feel
very real including the principal of the
school who also turns in a fantastic
performance the movie itself is a little
hokey at parts and isn't anything too
special but it's filled with some great
characters and contains Kiana's best
performance to date check it out to see
Reeves at his best
for more content over in my personal
channel a John wick verses taken video
has just been posted which is the better
older guy revenge flick find out I want
to hear what you guys think what is your
favorite Keanu Reeves movie and/or
performance what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know to keep in touch you could like
my Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome walter b or follow along on
twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future i'll
see you next week with the worst of our
moo
excellent friend on a brand-new episode
of top five
[Music]
you